[Music]
this is Jonathan pecho welcome to the
symbolic world
hello everyone I've been wondering for a
while whether or not I should weigh in
on the whole debate which happened
between Jordan Peterson and Santa hat
sam harris on the question of truth
though i'm sure that for those who've
been following me you can surmise what i
think about this already maybe at some
point I'll put something together but in
the meantime I wanted to give you a
short comment which is moving in that
direction let's say so a few weeks ago
now at on the on the Joe Rogan podcast
with with jordan peterson and brett
weinstein they had a discussion
commenting on the whole harris peterson
conflict about truth and just like sam
harris weinstein and joe rogan just
couldn't grasp the extent of this
question and that's really a problem
there really is a kind of blindness to
consciousness and blindness to the
extent to which the scientific truth
that they love so much is embedded into
religious structures embed it into
language embedded into patterns of being
I mean I don't want to go into the
argument too much and if you you you
want a more detailed description please
watch my video how scientists nested in
religion what I'm about to show you well
suffice to demonstrate to all of you how
inescapable all of this is now the first
thing I have to say is that I have the
utmost respect for Brent Weinstein I
think that he acted forthrightly I think
that he acted heroically in standing up
to the politically correct bullies and I
wish that there would be more professors
like him in the North American
University system and and honestly I
hope that this difficult moment for him
will become an opportunity to do much
more than what he's had to leave behind
so let's start with the basic argument
I'm going to play a little clip of his
attempt to reconcile the two positions
which were presented by by Jordan
Peterson and Sam Harris we tend to think
of intellect has evolved
as having evolved because knowing what's
true gives you an advantage but there's
actually nothing that says the literal
truth is where advantage lies and so I
have a category that I call literally
false metaphorically true these are
ideas that aren't true in the factual
sense but they are true enough that if
you behave as if they were true you come
out ahead of where you would be if you
behaved according to the fact that
they're not true
so according to tutu mr. Weinstein there
are these factual truths with which
correspond to scientific truth I guess
which he opposes to metaphorical truths
which are factually untrue but contain a
form of wisdom which can be useful so I
think that his categories are inadequate
but you know obviously we would say that
symbolic truth contains the wisdom there
the usefulness but does not necessarily
have to be non factual but uh
at least for now I'm willing to go with
him on this let's just follow through
and see where it goes so after he gives
a few examples of how these two truths
relate to each other and then Jordan
gives a few points weinstein then go on
goes on to say this there is this
overarching truth the one that sam
harris was pointing to the one i think
you're pointing to also and the one i
i'm imagining we all subscribed to sure
right there is the testable truth that
reveals itself in the laboratory were in
a careful experiment in the field and
that really is the top-level truth but
no did you notice what just happened
here so beyond the the the slightly
condescending tone of wanting to
attribute his opinion about scientific
truth to everyone in the room as if
obviously we all agree that scientific
truth is the top level truth is the
overarching truth I mean it's so obvious
that he would not dare to think one so
simple-minded as to consider anything
else and then he it's funny because he
kind of does a double take looking at
Jordan because that is exactly the point
Jordan has been arguing against
with Sam Harris but beyond that can you
spot the supreme irony because the only
way he can make his point about the
superiority of testable truth that
reveals itself in the laboratory is by
using a metaphorically true but
factually false using his own structure
to say it so he so he has to say that
this testable truth is top-level truth
but you know I looked for hours on that
top shelf and I couldn't find it but the
second one is better because he says
that factual truth is the overarching
truth which which reaches sublime levels
of irony and contradiction because well
number one obviously if you look over
your head you will not see this testable
factual truth and number two if we even
look at what that means how an
overarching truth is precisely a truth
in which other truths are embedded it's
not just truth but it's you know the
truth of truth let's say or the the
structure in which other truths are
contained and then in his very statement
he embeds factual truth within the
metaphorically true but factually false
language of hierarchy which is you know
by using the the language of up and
allusions to heaven and transcendence it
is the very language of religion but
number three which in my opinion is the
most maddening because 99% of your life
of your decisions of your consulta of
your constituting your worldview your
representation of the world you do not
have access to those laboratory tested
truth that you are so keen upon in fact
we barely ever have access to those
tests what we have access to are the
retelling of those tests and the results
by other people that is the overarching
truth II
for scientists it is not the tested
experiments which almost no one has done
themselves in order to know them but
rather it is our trust in a community of
people to accurately represent the
experiments that they have done so it's
really important to see this because
there is this this idea that faith or
that trust is something which
necessarily is a giving a way of reason
or giving a way of empirical knowledge
whereas in truth it is the basis of our
existence that is 99% of the decisions
you make 99 percent of the the
information that you believe is based on
trust because you have not done the
experiments yourself and you could not
do the experiments yourself you trust a
community of scientists that they are
being forthright with you and that they
are representing the facts accurately so
this is not as simple as as many of the
new atheist types would have us believe
if you enjoyed this content and our
exploration of symbolism get involved I
love to read your comments in the
comment section below please go ahead
and share this on social media to all
your friends and also please consider
supporting us financially on patreon
you'll find a link to the patreon page
in the description below